nous voici à l'hiver 1869 noël se
prépareront la maison de famille de
georges sand
la table est dressée prête à recevoir
les convives
elle fera venir à nohant les plus beaux
esprits de l'époque une vraie fraternité
y règnera l'histoire veut que flaubert
soit le premier arrivé en ce soir de
noël les bras chargés de cadeaux
c'est pour cela que la mine table salle
à manger et décorer les mâles de george
sand pour été posée dans le vestibule
pour recréer cette ambiance que george
sand émettant fêter noël avec ses
petites filles vers les années 1870
horreur l'aîné à 3 ans et sa charmante
petite soeur gabrielle un an et demi
c'est une ambiance de fête du 19e siècle
qui est recréé au domaine de nohant des
dizaines de visiteurs sont venus
découvrir ou redécouvrir des pièces de
collection privée exposée le temps de
quelques semaines françois le champion
très intéressant de découvrir cette
femme que l'on connaît qu au travers de
ses romans finalement aux traditions
rythme de vie de sa maison toute son
histoire extrêmement intéressant une
histoire marquée justement par des fêtes
de noël la toujours très joyeuse et
c'est le lendemain de noël les 821 que
sa grand mère décède à nohant en le
prononçant ses derniers mots tu perds ta
meilleure amie
après le repas préparés dans les
cuisines du domaine par la dizaine de
domestique
c'est le moment pour george sand et ses
amis de rire un peu pourquoi pas devant
les marionnettes du petit théâtre
c'est la septième fois qu adam vient
visiter la maison de l'auteur il est
toujours sous le charme
cette fois ci c'est quand même différent
ils ont mis beaucoup de choses que je
n'ai jamais vu dans la cuisine parce et
ça fait animer ses tresses et très bien
j'adore cette maison s'est plongé dans
un noël autant de george sand est à
découvrir jusqu'au 6 janvier au domaine
de nouveau